- Good morning,
thrilled to be here.
Sorry I'm a little delayed,
mother nature never loses.
What I really want to
do is actually pontificate
a little bit,
they've given me a time slot
and I decided as I was
looking at the social mentions
and just kind of the
context of this event,
that a lot of people
actually did have context
for my spiel, some have
shared the stage with me,
others have been engaging and
so I decided to actually cut
my chatting down a little bit
because the truth is
as a lot of you know,
I'll put out my general
thoughts on entrepreneurship
and business on
pretty much a daily basis,
I thought what would
be much more interesting
is actually try to do
as much Q&amp;A as possible.
So, because what I think
is then I can answer
your questions and
I find that even when I answer
them very specifically that
takes care of 20 or 30 percent
of the audience's
questions, so I'll get into that
in a little bit,
but first I'll give you
a little bit of the chat.
You know, I've been
thinking a lot lately
about this whole journey
about how entrepreneurship
has become something of a status
and has been put on a pedestal.
I've also been
thinking about how scary it is
when something
becomes cool or interesting
and what that creates
and I've been pondering
that quite a bit
which is the differences
between being an entrepreneur
and being a
successful entrepreneur.
You know, putting the
fact that you're a CEO
in your Instagram
profile doesn't mean that
it's what you're
gonna be able to do
for the rest of your life
and what I'm really concerned
about is that we have lived
both in Canada and the US,
with basically a
eight to nine year macro,
almost a decade of
good economic growth.
We just have.
You know obviously there was a
crash in the US in 2008, '09.
But if you look at the data,
we're probably on the tail end
of economic growth,
obviously nobody knows,
otherwise they would
make trillions of dollars
but one of the things
that I did want to talk
to guys about
today is practicality.
I think practicality stunningly
not talked about enough
so for example, if you're
running a business right now
and it's predicated
on raising money
or you've raised money
and you lose money each month,
it's probably a really
good idea to change course
pretty quickly.
Because the biggest
issue for me right now,
is that we have a lot of people
who want to build brands,
who want to become influencers,
who want to start companies
but they're not putting
in the pieces that
actually allow them
to weather the storm.
You know the thing
that I'm most proud of
is the two biggest
businesses I've ever built,
I basically started them
during very difficult times.
When I first got involved in
my dad's liquor store business,
it was the late '90s and
just about a year and a half
into my journey, I guess
two years into my journey,
the stock market crashed and
all the internet companies
folded and all the
people that were making money
that I was
targeting to sell wine,
stopped having
money to buy wine.
And then right behind that,
because most of my business
was New York and New
Jersey based, even though
we were building
an internet company,
it was only about a
year later that 9/11 happened
and not only,
changed, I mean for anybody
that lived in New York,
New Jersey area,
it was much more
compounded for us
because we lost
loved ones and I remember
I lost 100 employees from
one organization in one day.
I had to go in hand by
hand and take their emails out
because everybody passed
away from Canter Fitzgerald
that worked in that office.
So I persevered through
that because I was practical.
Because I didn't
have a lot of overhead
and because I wasn't
romantic, I wasn't dreaming,
I knew that I had
to buy and sell wine
and liquor and beer
and I had to make sure
that my expenses
weren't greater than the money
I was bringing in.
VaynerMedia started in the
ashes of the economic meltdown
of the U.S., when I started
VaynerMedia, people didn't want
to pay $5,000,
let alone the $50 or $100,000
they pay us a month
now for our services.
And when I started VaynerMedia,
you know it's funny,
I watch everybody
watch my journey now
and there's that cliché thing
of overnight success, right?
I'm going to have this
TV show come out this June.
And it's going to
change my profile right?
I'm going to sit on
a stage with Will.i.am
and Gwyneth Paltrow
and Jessica Alba
for this Apple show
that I'm about to do
and everybody's going to
say where'd he come from,
that happened
overnight, you know.
And it's even
really happened in social,
I'm sure for a lot of you,
you've only really even
have known about me for
the last six months or so,
even though I've been
putting out content online
for 10 years every single day.
And so the thing
that I've been really
thinking about is practicality.
Like VaynerMedia even
though I had already built
a nice size business,
it wasn't like I was extracting
a lot of money
out of Wine Library
and so when AJ and I started
VaynerMedia, seven years ago,
we started it out
of a company called
BuddyMedia's conference room.
For the first two years
that I ran VaynerMedia,
we had no rent.
We first worked
out of a conference room,
a conference room.
We then worked out of a
co-working space before
the whole WeWork and
co-working space revolution,
and I bartered my
time to help that company
in exchange for
a very small space.
We didn't buy furniture.
We scrapped.
And I'd already made it.
I was already rich.
And we scrapped.
And so the biggest thing that
I wanna implore everybody
here today to do
is to take a step back
and think about
how fancy are they?
Are you willing to be
really, really, really ghetto?
Do you really need that chair?
Do you really need
that piece of technology?
Do you really
need to fly that class?
Like, I just think
that we're living through
an incredibly fancy
culture of entrepreneurship.
Entrepreneurship and
CEO status is quite sexy.
People are selling a
lifestyle that is filled with
lots of fun and trips
and champagne and bikinis
and bling-bling and all
sorts of horse shit, right?
(audience laughter)
And I just think that
that era of this era is gonna
come to an end somewhere
within the next five years,
and very honestly, I just
don't want a lot of people
in this room that dream
to build their own businesses
to have to go work at a bank,
or go work at a retail store,
and so I would highly recommend
something that I think
is stunningly not
talked about enough, which is,
if you're building a business,
you have to be making money.
(audience applause)
And so, I know that's
like a funny thing to say,
but I think it's important.
I think the other
thing that's important
is to shift the context
completely the other way,
which is what is
really winning, right?
Like, what is the
definition of winning,
and I think we all have
different definitions, right?
And I think that one
of the things that I also
wanna say is that I'm getting
scared that a lot of people
that are following my
journey hear me talking about
buying the New York Jets,
and I do aspire to buy
a three-billion dollar
sports franchise, I do,
it is what I want, you can
look at my fifth grade yearbook
long before business was
cool, it's what I wanna do.
But I'm awfully
scared that it's pressuring
the people that follow me
into trying to achieve things
that they don't necessarily
want, they just think it's
the thing you do
if you're trying to be
a successful businessperson.
Let me promise you something.
I know tens of
thousands of people,
and I know thousands
of people extremely well,
and I know hundreds
of people deeply well.
There is no correlation
between how much money
someone makes and
their level of happiness.
I have friends who
make $47,000 a year,
and they're the
happiest people I know.
Their work/life
balance is on point,
they're part of
two soccer teams,
they play video games,
they watch every show they want,
they take two vacations
that they scrap together,
and they're
freaking happy as well.
And I know tons of
people who I grew up with
in the Silicon Valley
boom who have hundreds
of millions of
dollars in their bank account
and are as
miserable and as lonely
and as broken
as you'll ever see,
so I implore all of you
to please reverse engineer
and figure out who you are,
and figure out what level of
monetizing and stuff you need,
and what level of
creativity you need.
I promise you one thing,
one thing that will
catch you very off-guard.
I should be way more rich.
I leave money on
the table every day.
I've left ungodly amounts
of money on the table.
I spend tons of time sending DMs
and engaging with people
and meeting people randomly
and not cashing in.
I actually believe the
statement I'm about to make.
I think that I love
the journey and the game
of entrepreneurship so much
that I have subconsciously
sabotaged my financial upside
to make sure I can
play this a little longer,
'cause I fear if the
numbers keep getting too big,
eventually, it will
take the fun out of it.
When you are
lucky enough like I am
to actually do something
that you love so much,
do something that puts
pressure against the one thing
you care about besides it,
which is the time
I spend with my family.
My family's my whole life,
and being this and doing this
is the only thing
that cuts into that.
I couldn't breathe if
I wasn't an entrepreneur.
I didn't breathe when
That's the reason I got
D's and F's in school.
'Cause I just couldn't be me,
and I'm not capable of that.
And so, I think
being here excites me
because I think coming
to not L.A., San Francisco,
New York, London, is
always more fun for me.
It always feels a
little more practical.
It always feels like
there's a little bit more
chips on the shoulder,
which is what I have.
But I wanna remind everybody,
just 'cause you didn't
grow up with a trust fund,
just 'cause you don't
live in Silicon Valley,
the market doesn't care.
If you're good
enough, you will win,
and I hope that you don't ...
(audience applause)
It's true.
And if you sit
around and ponder,
well, if I didn't live here,
or if my mom
wasn't an alcoholic,
or if I just
learned about this earlier,
or if I'd been
following this person earlier,
or if I wasn't born a woman,
or if I wasn't born a minority,
if you sit and do that,
you are losing.
You're not wrong,
it's just that business
and marketing and
all this doesn't care.
There's just no
emotion in the market.
Like that's it.
And so I think we need
to start having much deeper,
much more serious conversations
of practicality, you know?
It's fun and I love
this space the most
but I loved it
long before it was sexy.
I loved it long
before people wanted
to take selfies with me.
I loved it long before
athletes and celebrities
and rappers wanted
to be entrepreneurs.
I loved it long before that.
It was my destiny.
It was who I was,
it was how I was wired,
it was the only
thing I knew, that's why
the four-year-old me
ripped flowers out of yards
and sold it.
You don't read about
being entrepreneur at
five, six,
seven, eight and nine.
I didn't jump on
this because it's cool now
and it makes me money and girls.
I did it 'cause
it's all I ever was.
And I implore you, if you came
here to be an entrepreneur
but this talk
allows you to realize
you're really an artist or
you're really a number three
in a company because you
bring this level of energy
and don't want
to be a number one
because let me promise
you something about being
a number one, I'm
not an entrepreneur,
I'm a fire fighter.
My entire life is
taking care of crap.
Putting out fires,
24/7/365, my whole life
is this is a problem.
Fix this and guess what?
When you're the
last line of defense,
there's no blaming your boss.
There's no blaming the logo.
There's no
blaming the government.
It's all my fault.
All of it.
And so, it's super sexy but
what's not being talked about
is the friends and
acquaintances I have
who've committed
suicide in the entrepreneur land
in the last four years.
Because nobody
talks about the downside.
Everybody thinks
they're going to be Zucks.
they're going to build Snapchat.
Go look at the data.
The data shows that the
far majority of this room
will not succeed,
not even close,
to building an actual business.
And I don't come
here to be somber.
I come here to
remind you that there's only
one thing you can do.
The only thing you
can do that can trump
the moment mommy and
daddy had sex to make you,
the only thing
that can trump that,
that can trump your DNA,
the only thing
that is controllable,
if you want it,
if you want this,
is work.
(audience applause)
It is.
It's the only tangible,
and by the way,
I don't know if
you've guys noticed,
I've stopped even,
and it's funny given
the name of the conference,
I've started using
the word work more
than the word hustle
just because I want
everybody to understand
what we're really
talking about here.
If you've got a big mouth
and a lot of you do here,
searched the hashtag and a lot
of you say CEO/Founder/Owner.
I call that big mouth.
If you've got
the audacity to do it
and so many of you
have heard this from me,
when I audit you and I do,
because I'm curious,
it's how I learn,
people talk a big game.
I especially love when
somebody hits me up on social,
like Gary Vee,
you're gonna buy the Jets,
I'm gonna buy
the Rams, you know?
(audience laughter)
Everybody's
buying a sports team.
And I love to look
at what that person does
and then I'll DM
that person and be like,
"Yo bro, nobody, nobody, unless
they were a trust fund baby,
"ever bought the
Rams when they go skiing
"for a week when they're 24."
Nobody you know, nobody you
know,
nobody you know,
has become successful, outside
of it being given to them
from their family, nobody
you know has actually created
success without
working their face off.
It doesn't exist.
So you can sit
and talk about luck
and you can sit and talk about
this that or the other thing
but I promise you, the only
controllable thing you have
is your work ethic.
So going back to the
beginning of my talk,
you need to ploy serious,
serious self-awareness
and figure out who you are.
I implore you to start
matching your work ethic
and your actions to your mouth.
If you're gonna
be a billionaire,
you need to
realize that most people
that create billion
dollars worth of wealth,
don't do anything
besides work, every single day
of their 20's and 30's.
All of them.
Every person that
works at VaynerMedia
has taken more
vacations in the last 13 months
than I did in my
entire 20's and early 30's.
My family went on two family
vacations my entire childhood.
I was married to
my wife for five years
before we had a family,
we took two vacations.
It's the price you
have to pay if you want it
at the level that I want it at.
And by the way, I advise nobody
to want it at that level.
(audience laughter)
I'm being dead serious,
this is a very true statement
that I think most of
you will not believe,
but I'm telling you
it's the goddamn truth.
If there was a drug that
could take some ambition out,
I would take it.
It is so extreme, it is all in.
The reason I started
DailyVee was to remind you
that I'm outworking you,
that when you talk and
you're trying to figure it out,
when you're trying to
say you're gonna be like me,
I want you to see it, I want you
to see every other day, 5 A.M.,
I want you to see
every day midnight,
all of them, every day,
always, forever.
(audience laughter)
That's what it
takes for what I want.
Good news is, between what
I want and what is achievable
and is considered
unbelievably all-time happy
is a big gap.
So there's
plenty of vacation time.
I know tons of
people with vacation time,
I know tons of people
with work-life balance,
that do tons of fun activities
and make seven figure,
millions of dollars a year
and love it.
I'm playing for legacy,
I'm playing for all-time,
I'm looking to
impact every generation
that comes behind me
because I wanna show
that you can
build all-time wealth,
all-time greatness doing it
the right way and the old way.
That's what I'm up to.
So please make sure
you understand that,
and, more importantly, make
sure you understand yourself
so that you can
reverse engineer that blueprint
and figure out
where you fit within that
and then deploy it,
but I promise you,
you will not get there
with your big idea.
I promise you, sitting around
and saying, "Oh, (snaps fingers)
I had that idea for Uber
"before Uber did."
(audience laughter)
Nobody gives a shit.
I've got every idea
that's gonna be successful
over the next hundred
years, it's all about AI
and VR and AR and
augmented and all this,
I'll give 'em to you all. It
doesn't matter,
'cause most of you
won't execute against it.
The reason I put
out all my best stuff
and I'm liked and
I don't charge for it
is somewhere along the line
I realized that 99.9% of you
aren't gonna do
anything about it.
(audience laughter)
You're gonna ponder it, you're
gonna get super pumped up
when you watch me say it
and then three weeks
later you're gonna give up,
'cause you're not
willing to pay the price.
And that's cool,
everybody's different.
But you need to
figure out what price
you are willing to
pay for what you want.
It has been insane
to me how many people
have emailed me
in the last month
about the 2017 Flip Challenge,
which for you that don't know,
was a video I made in December,
which is, so many of you
email me asking me for $5,000
and meanwhile
there's $5,000 worth of crap
sitting in your house right now,
go grab it,
post it on eBay, flip it,
and make your money.
How many people
have flipped something
since they saw that video?
Raise your hands,
just wanna see.
Higher, higher, don't be shy!
That's it, you know, like,
it's insane people emailing me
like, "Hey this,
like, I just made $8,000
"'cause I sold $100 of
this, then this happened,
"and this happened,
and this happened."
Funny thing happens
when you actually work.
(audience laughter)
Go figure.
Funny thing happens when you
actually realize it's money
that gives you the opportunity.
Everybody's got a big idea,
everybody's got
the Uber of lawnmowers,
everybody's got the Airbnb of
ice cream. (audience laughter)
It's not gonna happen.
And if it does, please,
take the clip of this talk,
email me and say in the title,
"Garyvee, you were wrong."
And I will be
the first to call you
and say,
"Mazel Tov, I am so pumped."
(audience laughter)
But I just wanna remind every,
especially 20 and
30-year-old in this room,
I came out the gate
and I worked every day
for 13 years before I said
a goddamn word to anybody.
I talk a whole lot
now, and I've made up
for those 13 years
of silence (chuckles).
(audience laughtr)
but I just
wanna remind everybody
that I didn't make
a video to the world
about anything about business
until I was 35 years old,
after I worked every single day
from the time I was
22 and, in reality, 14,
and then I started talking.
There's a whole lot
of talking going on,
how about more action?
How about more execution?
How about more paying prices
for what your mouth is saying?
That is what I hope you do.
Thank you.
(audience applause)
- That felt good.
- [Woman] Hello, hello!
Gary thank you so much for
coming here, we know it was
a very tough road for
you to get here today.
This guy's a trooper.
If you guys only knew.
Could we get another round of
applause over here for Gary?
(audience applause)
For making this a priority!
This guy went through hell
and high water to get here,
and we are so thankful.
So we're gonna do a couple
of questions, as we told you.
We have a bunch of
questions from Twitter,
so we'll start there, and
then we're definitely gonna
come around to
some audience questions.
Okay Gary.
- Yes.
- First question via Twitter.
- How important
is it to take risks
when you're starting a business?
- I mean, I think it
comes down to your talent.
So one of the things
that I'm fascinated by
is how many people
are scared to take risks,
and then take credit for things.
For example, let me explain.
The amount of
businesses that I've looked at
over the last decade, that
are doing $1 million,
$2 million,
$4 million,
$8 million in sales
and are successful,
and the founder is kind
of making fun of other people
for different things,
and then I remind them,
that if I had run their
business, instead of doing
two million, it
would be doing 19.
They take a step back, and
then I try to explain to them
in detail, and
here's where I'm getting at.
Everybody's got their own
cadence and their own talent.
But taking risks is how
you make real things happen.
It's how you take quantum leaps.
The amount of things
I failed at, at VaynerMedia,
from an agenda standpoint,
over the last seven years,
is enormous, because I take
micro-risks all the time.
Risks that, if they
go to zero, which is how
I think about them, will
not put me out of business.
But risk, for example,
took a lot of risks last year.
Last year we did
$100 million in revenue.
The year before, we did 67.
We mad the same amount
of money in both years.
Risks.
Lost 33 million dollars
of profit against that gross,
you know, probably left
six, seven million dollars
in profit on the table,
because I took risks.
The good news is, one
of those risks is probably
gonna make me 50 more
in revenue in three years.
So I think risks are
imperative, and I want to remind
the people here, who
are conservative, you know,
that's great, and
if you're at the number
that you want to be at, great.
The one thing I would say is,
the biggest fear I have
for people that don't take
risks, is that your competitors
might, and then
you're in trouble.
So a lot of people think
it's insular, but it's not.
Maybe the person that
owned the most cab medallions
in New York should have taken
a risk and built a cab app.
- True, very true.
- Maybe, maybe
The Hilton, right.
Maybe The Westin, maybe
Four Seasons should have
taken a risk and
created a platform where we rent
each other our
own rooms, you know?
So risks are important.
- On that note though,
just to follow-up.
Do you think
that larger companies
are more adverse to risk?
- A hundred percent.
And I think small
companies are scared of risk.
I think people are scared.
I think people lack self esteem.
- You're helping that
situation, let me tell ya.
- I'm trying.
- Okay, so that question,
just to give a shout-out,
that question was from
wojackter, DJ Wojackter.
- Alright.
- And our next Twitter question.
Am I saying that right?
- No no, he might not be here.
Twitter's open to everyone.
(audience laughs)
- You are right, you are right.
We did put out the
hashtag this morning.
No it's our own, it's
our HHAskGaryVee hashtag so,
hopefully he is here, or she,
or whatever heard that question.
Our next one from Blair Kennedy.
Will you ever open a
VaynerMedia office in Canada?
- Yes.
- Really?
(audience applause)
Okay, so let us know
when that's happening,
and we'll help you guys apply.
- I promise you'll know.
- Awesome, awesome.
Okay let's go to an audience
question, oh my goodness.
How am I gonna decide?
- Who's got the mic?
You got the mic?
- Okay good, you're not
leaving it up to me.
- Pick anyone.
I'm gonna hang as long as I can.
I'll answer as many as I can.
Just give me your name.
- [Pedro] Pedro, hi.
- Pedro, what's up brother?
- I'm fucking so
nervous right now, okay.
(audience laughter)
- Can you stand up?
- Gary, you changed my life.
- I promise most people
didn't think that I'd be
the second person to
drop an F-bomb today.
(audience laughter)
Go ahead, Pedro.
- [Pedro] Thank you so,
you changed my life.
Just wanted to
let you know that.
- Thank you.
- I'm an advertising
student and, I sit in class,
I'm in second year.
I'm so nervous,
I sit in class and I--
- They teach you crap.
- [Pedro] Yeah, and I
learn more from you so,
I want to give
you value, but I want
an internship as well
so, if I can flip for you
on stage, could you
offer me an internship?
- No.
- [Pedro] No worries.
- A flip?
- [Pedro] Yeah.
- Do you think you flipping
was enough value for me?
- [Pedro] I think it's
entertainment for you.
- Not for me, you
don't know me super well.
(audience laughter)
- [Pedro] Alright no worries,
I'll accept that
punch in the face.
- Let me tell you why I told
you no and let me tell you
where I want to go with it.
I wrote a book called
Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook.
I'm about to teach you more
about selling and marketing
right this second
than anything you'll learn
in any school ever.
- [Pedro] Thank you, tell me.
- When you give with
expectation in return, you lose.
(audience applause)
- [Pedro] Thank you.
- Jab, jab, jab, right hook,
is give, give, give, and
too many people interpret it
as take.
Jab, jab, jab, right hook is
give, give, give, and then ask.
And so that's the cadence,
especially when you're asking
for something as big time
as an internship
at Vayner that has
become super competitive,
that's when you've
gotta do your homework
on what the value is.
It's awesome that you can
do a flip and that would be
cool on camera
feels super selfish,
I feel like you
were gonna win twice.
You were gonna do a
rad ass flip onstage
and get an internship.
That's not only
giving with expectation,
that's asking twice.
That's why you get
a big fat no, Pedro.
- [Pedro] I appreciate it,
I appreciate it,
thank you, thank you.
(audience applause)
- Okay, okay we're gonna go
back to a Twitter question.
Give us one second
afterwards we'll allow it.
- Don't hack it,
you'll lose too.
Next.
- We'll do a Twitter
question and then there'll be
some opportunity after so
this one comes from skeptic,
and this is a question I
know a lot of people have.
What is the future of VR for
music artists and we do have
some artists in the crowd
here some actual celebrities
so I'm sure they're all
very interested to hear.
- VR is the only platform that
exists that I know of that
has the potential to arbitrage
out the internet itself.
Right, so if you
really think about it.
Super VR-ed out.
He's right, but here's where
some of the VR friends that
I have aren't as happy with me.
I just think it's a good 15
to 25 years away because it's
massive consumer behavior.
It reminds me so much
of the internet in '92.
Right, we're still in 2017 we're
talking about 25 years later and
still only 30%, 15% of
stuff is bought online but,
when you think
about what VR actually is,
which is at scale you put
contact lenses in your eyes
and you live.
You live, you're just living.
And it's really no different
than the way you're living
through your phone right now.
Think about how much you go
to your phone and how much you
watch other people
go to their phone,
we're living already in VR.
It's called this.
It gets crazy different when
you put it over your eyes and
it all feels that way and so
the stuff I've been playing
with is so intense.
The first time I took off a
very substantially strong,
ahead of its time VR
set a year or so ago,
I'll never forget what I
said which really caught me
off guard 'cause it was
just a very natural reaction.
I took it off,
it was super HD,
the audio 'cause sound
is a big issue was on point,
the kids that were doing it
reminded me much more of the
internet kids that I grew up
with which is straight nerds.
Not like business guys that
want to be in it 'cause it's
cool right? And I just
remember taking off the headset
and I said,
"Holy crap why would
anybody ever take this off?"
And then I took a
step back and said oh man,
so I think what's
in it for musicians?
The same thing
that's in it for everybody.
Production companies
are gonna pop up,
produce experiences and it's
going to be the same thing
we just saw with the internet.
Somebody'll be the Amazon and
somebody'll be the YouTube.
It's the complete
reset of opportunity.
Some of the incumbents
from the internet age
will do a good job,
maybe YouTube does a
good job and stays as an
entertainment platform,
maybe two kids
here create the next
YouTube in that environment.
But the stakes are very high
and I will tell you a lot of
people in this room will be
very scared of it 'cause their
children will live in a world
where they never have to
physically move anywhere.
And that's gonna change our
world but I do think it's much
further away than
people think and so we'll see.
- [Woman] Awesome, and hopefully
there'll be some VR that helps
people move right you can
run like you're running the
Boston Marathon in Chicago.
- Yeah but I think we as
humans always worry about that
stuff like everyone's
talking about exercise,
we're healthier than ever.
Just because we're in our
phone all the time or play
video games all the time,
we're not talking about the
fact that we eat so much better.
We're not talking about
that so many people work out
every single day now.
Who's over 40 years
old raise your hands?
Great, good amount.
Remember, nobody was
healthy 20 years ago.
(audience laughter)
Like nobody everybody ate
Doritos and drank soda and
nobody went to the gym.
So we're taking
things in micro too much,
oh we gotta get
people healthier.
We're the healthiest
we've ever been and it is not
even close and just because
we're in the phone instead
of on a television and on
Nintendo doesn't mean we're
less healthy.
- [Woman] Totally,
very, very true.
Okay let's go back
to an audience question.
Our mic picker will have
the responsibility there.
- [John] Gary,
I've got a question for you.
- [Gary] What's your name man?
- [John] My name's John,
it's not as sexy as pedro.
- [Gary] No worries.
Did you say John?
- [John] I did.
- Okay, awesome.
- [John] I got a
question about ambition.
You talked about risk as well.
- Yes.
- [John] So for those of us
that dream big, what do you
know about
running a football team?
- Running a football team?
- [John] Or owning one
versus having a family,
and then how do you equate
that over to the idea of
this, you know you talked
about this endless
ambition and that balance
that you're trying to strike.
The prioritization there,
I mean, those are two deep,
huge engagements, let
alone all the other businesses
that you have.
- Yeah, so hold on
to the mic, 'cause maybe
we'll clarify here.
So I think, I think one of
the biggest reasons I don't
tell anybody how to parent,
or how to map their ambition,
or give relationship advice,
is we all have different stuff.
The serendipity of my life,
create a scenario where
the woman that I married
grew up in a household where
her father traveled
all the time, right.
She has the greatest
relationship with him.
They worked in extremes.
He worked a lot and
they vacationed a lot,
and things of that nature.
And I grew up in a very
similar household where,
mine was even more extreme.
There was no extremes, it was
one gear, all working and,
we're also a very
old school couple.
We're a little bit more
into dividing and conquering.
You know obviously we have
a whole lot of co-parenting
and things of that nature,
but, and I don't think
one's right or one's wrong,
I just know what Lizzie
and I are comfortable with,
and that's Lizzie and I.
And it's very cute and nice,
that there's lots of books
written about what we
should do, and it's very nice
that you have
opinions of how I should do it,
but I don't give a shit.
- [John] No but, I
want you to tell me
you struggle with that, maybe.
- But I don't.
- [John] Do you
struggle trying...okay (laughs).
Then I feel even worse.
- Let me tell you
what I struggle with,
if you're looking for something.
I struggle being
completely petrified of anybody
that I love dying.
Like crippled.
Like, when my mom goes to
the doctor, I can't think.
For a checkup.
That's what I struggle with.
After that, feels
very controllable.
It's binary for me brother.
You know, it's all I got.
(audience applause)
Because I'm not scared about
my kids not loving me, right.
Because I also know
there's so many yings and yangs.
I know that my
daughter is going with me
on two speaking
engagements, in the next year,
and that when I go speak in
Anaheim, I'll take the next
day off with her, and
we'll go to Disneyland
and have that time.
I don't remember
anything about what my parents
did with me from 10 to,
you know from six to 13,
other than the one time
my mom took me out of school,
on my birthday in fourth grade
and took me to the arcade.
People don't understand how
memory and the brain works.
And by the way, let
me remind all the parents
that feel great about
their work-life balance.
Coming home and being on
your phone and watching TV,
doesn't mean you're with them.
People confuse
quality and quantity.
(audience applause)
So, you know but, but
let me tell you something.
Things change man.
You know like, with all the
audacity that I just delivered
this with, I could walk into
my home seven months from now,
Lizzie could look me
in the face and says,
I'm done with this, too much.
And then I got a real
problem, 'cause then I have to
decide between two things I
can't breath without, you know?
And so I get it.
I get it.
I don't sit here thinking
I've got it all figured out,
and then life's
got twists and turns.
Everything's great,
until your child is diagnosed
with a life-threatening disease.
I promise you this.
If I ever shut my
mouth, it's only gonna be
because of the
health of my family.
If you ever don't see me
again, that's what I'm doing.
And I'll be back
when that's resolved.
But I'm not stressed by most
of the stuff in the middle,
especially in the current
political correctness POVs
of what we should be doing.
Cool.
(audience applause)
- [Woman] Awesome.
So, Gary, just
keeping on that note,
how important do you
think it is to build like
a really core team
around you, people that really
support you, and
understand the hustle?
- Imperative, but I
think the biggest core team
you need to create is
within your own brain.
- Can you explain
that a little further?
- If you're not your
biggest fan, you've lost.
- Amazing.
(audience applause)
We're going back to
Twitter for another question.
- And you know what,
let's stay on that for a minute.
- Sure.
- It's the big one.
It's the big one.
I think I give so much
'cause I actually think
I feel guilty that I was not
only gifted with the right DNA,
but I was parented so
perfectly that I could give
you that answer, because I
know almost every other person
I know doesn't have that
feeling about themselves,
and a whole lot of it
had to do with their mother,
or their dad, or
where they grew up.
So I feel, I feel,
enormous pain towards people
like my father, like a
lot of my best friends,
who weren't gifted with the
infrastructure of the household
that made them feel good about
themselves, but in return,
because their parents
were insecure, and sad inside,
they took it out
on their children,
and pointed out their flaws,
because misery loves company.
But I implore you,
if you're sitting with that,
in this audience, that
you need to figure out,
whether it's through
therapy, whether it's
with something else,
you've got to get that poison
out of your body, because if
you don't, you're just not,
you're just not going anywhere.
- [Woman] That actually leads
perfect into our next question,
and that comes
from Steven Gordon.
I'm gonna paraphrase this
a little bit, but it says,
every speaker has preached
positivity, and along those
lines pretty much everyone
out there, they want to know,
is that the final
key to unlocking success?
And anyone who follows
Gary, which I'm sure that's
pretty much everyone in
here, we've heard you talk
a lot lately about gratitude
and becoming a real person.
- Yeah.
Yeah I mean look,
I mean, what are we doing here?
Like, of course, like.
It's so easy, I've been
talking about this more,
and I think, with the political
climate in the States and,
other places in the world,
it's easy to sell negativity.
It's easy to be cynical.
You're protecting your feelings.
You don't want to be tricked.
It's hard to sell positivity.
People are
poking at that always.
It feels better,
it's tough to see it
when you don't have it.
I'm empathetic to that.
But sure, I mean, I talk
a lot in business context,
but whether you're a
parent or, in government like,
what do you want to do?
Why else would you, like
go through life not trying
to achieve happiness and
so, yeah, I think of course
that's the ultimate
goal and, it's incredible
what happens when
you feel good like,
everything's easy to
deal with, John, you know?
Everything's easy to deal
with 'cause, it's just life.
It's real, you know
like, I don't think,
I think people dwell.
And I think dwelling is,
the wrong strategy.
- It's focusing on
the wrong things, right?
You gotta focus
on what they want.
- Let me tell you
who's willing to listen
to you complain.
The people that are willing
to listen to you complain
and dwell, consistently,
only look two parts.
They're your most
inner-family and they love you
to the ends of the Earth,
or they're fellow loser friends.
(audience laughter and applause)
- Okay, awesome.
Let's give some love
to the sides over here.
Let's get a audience question.
Over here somewhere.
- She's a righty.
Hey.
- [Woman 2] Hi Gary.
I know you tell
us in your videos,
go in all-in on your strengths.
All chips in
on your strengths,--
- [Gary] Yes.
- [Woman 2] don't focus on
your weaknesses.
What have you seen, though,
from students at VaynerMedia,
students with internships.
What are their weaknesses,
or what's missing from those
students and from those people
that are asking for
that experience from you?
Not so that I can work on it,
but just so that I know
what people like you value
and what you need.
- I think everybody
has different
strengths and weaknesses.
I break things up into black
and white and gray, EQ and IQ.
I think those are
the two pillars that
I look at when I look at somebody.
And some people have
hard skills out their ass.
Right? They can do everything
but they don't know how to
interact with the
other boys and girls,
and that ultimately
tumbles them. Right?
So, the reason I started
talking about something called
the Honey Empire
is that's what I want
everybody at Vayner to know.
In the beginning,
I valued honey more.
That's why I call
it Honey Empire.
So if you were a good
person and you could get along
with everybody else, you worked
at Vayner for quite a while.
'Cause that was what I valued.
We're now seven,
we're now bigger.
If you've raised a child,
you know things change,
you expect more
as they get older,
and so I expect
more of the organization.
So we went through a tough
patch over the last six months
where I had to let
go of certain people
because I deemed that they
didn't have the hard skills.
The actual intellect,
the actually ability,
the output.
Crossing T's, dotting I's,
black and white stuff.
The math skills, the email
copy skills to have a client.
The strategy skills to come
up with an idea that mattered.
And it was very
shocking to our company
and a lot of feelings got hurt,
but it's the right thing to do
because meritocracy matters.
If you don't do that,
the winning players leave.
And so I think most people
fall in one of two categories.
They're short in one of the
two and if they have both,
they'll go on to win,
and if they have neither,
they're in really deep shit.
- [Woman 2] Yeah,
ultimately you need both,
but I feel like a
lot of businesses say,
oh it's all about
the personality,
it's all about the EQ,
it's all about those things.
Obviously you say you
were a D and an F student,
you were able to
build your own empire, but
showing up somewhere and
saying you have no skills
but you have lots of EQ,
not gonna get you very far.
- Businesses don't hire on that.
Nobody hires on that.
That's why my
businesses grow so fast.
I actually do
hire on that at first,
so it creates a
cultural foundation
that allows me
to then do my thing
but most,
no business does that.
Like, this many
businesses do that.
They only hire on skills,
they only hire on résumé.
They don't what I do and
like the Alex De Simone's
Uber driver's
like, I want a job.
We're like, okay.
You know?
If Pedro offered me
some Jets memorabilia,
he'd have a job too.
(audience laughter)
So I think that, yeah.
- [Woman 2] I'll be sure
to find you some
Jets memorabilia.
(Gary laughs)
- I think you have
to reverse engineer
the person that
you're selling to. Right?
I think that people
that know me should speak to
their EQ qualities, 'cause
they know I over-index on that.
But you shouldn't be mad at
a company that clearly points
to the fact that they
clearly hire on skill and IQ.
They want you to
have a piece of paper
from a bullcrap university that
says you can do this thing,
and don't be mad at them.
That's what they want.
And yes, I think you're
very clear-minded,
but I don't feel bad for people
who are like, but they said.
It doesn't matter,
it's up to you
to dissect and
decode what people say.
Everything on you.
Everything's your fault.
You wanna really win in life?
You wanna get real happy?
You know why I'm really happy?
'Cause I think
everything's my fault.
If I don't
like it, I can change.
President of the United States.
I don't like it, I can move.
Like, what's
everybody's problem?
(audience laughter)
Adjust.
(audience applause)
I mean that.
Meaning, I don't have
to agree with his politics.
I'm just saying
that you're in charge.
And we are just not
historically contextualized.
I'm much happier
to deal through, you know,
political toughness
or economic downturn,
much cooler to deal
with than The Black Plague.
No, really!
I mean, like, somebody
dealt with The Black Plague.
(audience laughter)
Like, you have
relatives that died.
I mean, I know it's
funny, but it's true.
And like, you know, so I mean,
I don't know, I just don't
know how to complain.
I always think
somebody has it worse.
And if somebody has it
worse, you need to shut up.
Whoever is the 7.7, if
that's the number we're at,
whoever's in last place,
whoever that person is,
if there was a
world chart ranking
and Sally was dead last,
she can talk.
(audience laughter)
(audience applause)
- Okay, okay, awesome!
Everyone that
has my phone number,
I appreciate you
calling me and texting me
trying to get a
question to Gary right now.
Unfortunately, I can't answer
your phone call, I'm sorry.
We're gonna keep goin'.
- Can we do some more?
- Of course!
- I know we're
doing a wine tasting,
but can I sneak in a
couple more questions?
Yeah? Okay, awesome!
Let's keep going.
Let's go to the left side.
- Hold on, come
right over here, then.
You have the mic, so.
- [Amy] I don't know if it's--
Okay, it is working.
- Yeah, you're on.
- [Amy] Okay, I apologize.
My name's Amy.
But I've only seen
two of your videos.
I know everyone else
here pretty much knows you.
- [Gary] Watch this!
How many people have
never seen any of my stuff?
Raise your hands.
- [Amy] Oh, my god!
Way more than I thought, okay.
- One thing that's been
great about this talk is,
one more time, raise your hands?
One thing that's really great
is that I always
know that to be true.
- [Amy] Okay.
- You know what's amazing
about having a huge ego?
When you balance it
with enormous humility.
- [Amy] That is true.
- I think 99.9% of the
world doesn't know who I am.
Those hands shocked
some people, not me.
That was actually better
than I thought, I'll take it.
- [Amy] That's awesome!
Well, a lot of my friends,
like I've got a lot of
really high profile friends,
and they love you,
they watch you all the time.
- [Gary] Yeah, 'cause I'm great.
(audience laughing)
- But when you
came up and spoke,
you kind of scared me and
excited me all at the same time.
You challenged
everything that I thought
and called me on my crap, right?
- [Gary] Yep!
- And I am,
I've struggled
with this thing about,
I give from the heart,
give, give, give,
and I'm about to do the jab,
but at the same time
there's something in me
that tells me that
well, it's not very good to do--
- [Gary] Keep talkin', I'm here.
You're scared for the ask?
Well, let's start with something.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Do you believe
in what you're selling?
- Oh my God, I believe
more than anything.
And I'm out to change the world,
and I know I will.
- Okay. So what
are you asking for?
- I wasn't actually
coming to ask about that,
I'm looking for,
I have habits that
aren't necessarily the best.
I spend my money on
education and business,
but I overspend.
I have put all my
stuff into my own thing,
but I'm looking
for somebody to invest,
but also give me the,
and I'm not
necessarily asking you.
- [Gary] I can tell.
- Okay.
But what I'm
looking for is somebody
who can guide me
through the process and say,
"Well, that's not a very
smart business decision."
- [Gary] What're
you looking to sell?
- [Amy] I sell affirming arts.
So it's personal development
and creative arts combined.
- [Gary] You're selling
people your time and service
to make them better?
- Yes.
- [Gary] Okay.
- And products and
services to make them better.
- [Gary] Yep, yep.
- Yes.
- [Gary] And so, you
aren't a good salesperson?
- [Amy] Not yet.
- Okay.
Will you ever be?
- Oh, God, yeah.
- [Gary] Why?
- Because I want to.
- [Gary] That's not good enough.
- Because I go out and do it.
I don't watch your videos
because I'm actually learning,
taking training, I've just
recently created the product
and I'm finding out
where to put them all.
My marketing, I do
want to empower the world,
so I'm doing a world
empowerment now movement.
- Yep.
- [Amy] Planning to go for a
Guinness Book of World Records.
- But you need a partner?
- [Amy] I have a partner,
but I don't have
a financial partner.
I have somebody
who's been working with me
but I've been paying.
- [Gary] You need an accountant?
- No, I need somebody to invest.
- [Gary] You need money.
- I need money,
I need capital.
- [Gary] Why?
- Just to keep
her on long enough
for us to go
through and do this.
- So, how much
money do you need?
- [Amy] Not even 50,000.
- Is that a dollar?
- [Amy] Dollars.
(Gary laughs)
- So I don't know--
- [Amy] And then, I wasn't
even intending to say this.
- Yeah, no worries.
- [Amy] I just had this insight
that I had to have a
conversation with you.
- I'm glad.
Look, I think you have to sell
somebody to give you money.
- [Amy] Okay.
- So you should go do that.
- [Amy] Alright, I am
researching angel investors.
Are there any angel
investors in this group?
Not one?
Alright.
- [Gary] There's
people with money.
They're just people
that didn't like your pitch.
(audience laughter)
- Okay, that's true.
- [Gary] So what's important,
what's important,
and I'm not
saying that to razz you,
what's important is to
figure out how to define it
so that there are people that
do want to raise their hand,
and do want to do that.
And more importantly,
I would tell you,
it's really easy
to get to people.
So, here's what
I would do if I were you,
I would put together
your deck, how you explain it,
maybe it's a video
'cause you articulate well,
however you want
to communicate it,
and I would relentlessly ask.
- [Amy] Okay.
I will make a video and
I will relentlessly ask.
- Yeah, I mean
that's what you do.
- Great, thank you.
- [Gary] Good luck, awesome.
(audience applause)
- [Woman] Thank you, thank you.
Let's go back here somewhere
and get a little
love to this area.
Left side.
- [Amir] Perfect.
Check, oh okay.
So my name is Amir and
I actually work for the
co-founders of Elite Daily so
I'm sure you've heard,--
- [Gary] Awesome
man, yeah, congrats.
- out of New York,
so my question is,
I know you're kind of
showcasing that you're working
really hard and through social
media Instagram, SnapChat,
you're outworking everyone.
But what's the end goal like,
why are you doing the
60 Second Club or the
Five Minute Club,
where do you see
that in one year?
Is that some sort of proof
of concept with your clients?
- [Gary] Yeah,
I'm always testing,
everything I do is
always learning behavior right?
To me, it was when
I decided that Instagram was
disproportionately
getting the attention,
I wanted to understand
what was the right cadence to
create notification turn on
and how do I bring value
in return for it and
what's the right value prop of
returning it?
And then I saw that a lot
of people were posting but
was that bringing value to
the community which was why
I shifted it to
Five Minute Club,
and then I realized like
neither was really bringing value
but the 60 Second Club
brought a sense of urgency and
fun to people like tens
of thousands of them,
so I said let's switch it back.
Those are just
micro, micro-tactics
in me learning things
that could
eventually help clients,
could help Wine Library,
and just I'm an
entrepreneur, right?
So the end goal is to be on the
journey of entrepreneurship.
I'm a risk taker. I like
doing different things.
I don't like settling for
the same old thing and so
those are just tactics
of trying to learn different
platforms and capabilities
and trying to understand the
learnings from the behavior
of people reacting to it.
- [Amir] So there's
no really end goal,
is there an end goal
that in one year through this,--
- [Gary] No, I have zero
micro-end goals like that, zero.
Zero, zero.
I never ever, ever, ever think,
I've never said that
in one year, you know,
I don't have that goal.
I have one macro
goal which is to
feel like I left
it on the field
is probably the
best way I could put it.
You know, I'm sure all of us
have different versions of this,
I just have this feeling,
it's like moth
to the light, right?
I couldn't even
really explain it.
It's why I'm so comfortable
in it because it's been there
long before this.
20 years before the
internet it was there,
do you know what I mean?
It's just always been there.
I don't know why every single
weekend instead of playing
with my friends I wanted to
make my friends work with me
and wash cars. I mean
my poor friends that are
now coming out
of the woodworks,
I forgot how many of
them I made do things.
I don't talk about the
shoveling snow and the car wash
business and the miniature
golf course I built in my
friend's backyard I don't
talk about those things often,
but it's just who I am.
Same way people need to sing
or same way people need to cook
every night just need to cook.
I just need to business.
(audience laughter)
- [Amir] Do you think that kind
of sends a message to your
audience for
them to do the same.
You see you're following you're
posting this I'm working,
do you think that kind
of might create some deceit,
deceive their audience
that it's actual fake work
than real work 'cause my
ideology is I don't need to
SnapChat, I don't
need to Instagram
to show that I'm working.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- I'm working when
I'm not on there.
So I feel like there's
more wannabe-preneurs
that are
actually doing that.
- [Gary] Of course,
of course.
I think for me,
I have the right balance
of wanting to give back and
a lot of selfishness
to have the attention
and it works in my favor.
Because I feel good about both.
I love the attention and
I have that narcissistic DNA
and I love it,
I love taking selfies,
I love people.
Of course I would love it.
It feels nice.
My mom loved me so much
and complimented me every day
so much that when
I left the house I was like,
fuck this, I need more of that.
(audience laughter)
So I need that,
that's why I do it.
I'm also not scared.
A lot of my friends who don't
put themselves out there,
they don't want themselves out
there because there's things
that they don't want people
to uncover about them so
I'm not scared. That happens,
and it feels really good
getting 100 emails a day from
people whose lives are way
better because they stumbled on
some of your videos and
that's something that my quiet
friends who don't need that
who just need to build and
do their business,
they don't have that feeling.
So when my friends who tell me,
my God if you put this
energy into your full-time,
my friends will say things like
if people knew that GaryVee
was your side hustle,
if people knew how
much you're actually,
if you actually took all that
time and energy and put it
into your business you
wouldn't be doing $100 million,
you'd be doing $200 million.
And I always reply with
the same thing I'm like,
yeah but my legacy's
way better than yours.
You know and so you probably
know this after the exit of your
business it's crazy,
money after awhile
like how much do you need?
I don't know. I don't buy
shit like I don't need stuff.
- [Amir] It didn't
change anything,
the co-founders
lives stay the same.
- [Gary] Yeah, so you
know how it is.
And by the way I'm pumped
for people who their whole
life wanted a Lamborghini
and worked hard and got one,
good for them.
I don't judge other people's
stuff and I definitely don't
care how I'm being judged.
Cool.
(audience applause)
- [Woman] Amazing, amazing,
and when you get to a certain
level you get people wearing
shirts with your face on it.
See Gary's face over
here on a t-shirt.
- You want to talk
about narcissistic.
- GaryVeeShop.com
people, check it out.
Shirts like this.
We're gonna do one final
question I'm so sorry that
we have to wrap this up,
we have a final question
over here somewhere?
Okay I think they're gonna
come on stage to ask you the
question actually.
- Okay.
- Yeah, yeah, give
it up for GaryVee.
Hello, James Erdt here.
- How are you?
- Chair of the board for
Reviver Ranch for At-Risk Kids.
- How are you?
- Very good.
Very grateful.
So I'm coming here with a
pure attitude of gratitude.
To thank you and
your organization.
We have an original
15,000 dollar splotchy couture,
made out of
automotive paint from a 911,
from the different layers,
we can explain it later.
It comes with a
certificate of authenticity,
and we just wanted to
offer it to you as a thank you.
- Thank you, my friend.
(audience applause)
It's good to see ya.
How you been?
- Good.
- Alright, I don't need a mic,
I'm a theater performer.
There we are.
Gary, thank you so much.
How about it,
GaryVee everybody!
(audience applause and cheers)
Now.
We're not quite
done with you yet.
You know that,
because you
mentioned it earlier,
you couldn't wait
to get to this part,
because of the amazing success
that all got launched
through wine and spirits,
we have Richard Slingerland
is gonna join us
on stage right now,
from Pillitteri Estates Winery,
and I say we have
ourselves a wine test!
(audience applause)
- How are you?
- Nice to meet you.
Alright, so I'm very
happy to be here today.
Everyone can hear me okay?
Alright, awesome.
So I'm really excited because
I'm a Pillitteri family member,
for Pillitteri Estates Winery
in Niagara-on-the-Lake.
My job is a very difficult job.
I get to taste wine
with people for a living.
The Niagara wine region,
I know a lot of you
have been to our winery,
or around here.
It's really been incredible,
how much it's grown
over the last 20, 30 years.
It's hard to believe
when our winery opened,
there was only 16
wineries in Ontario.
Now there's over 220.
As well, I've mentioned
to a few people before,
we're actually the
second most traveled
wine route in the world.
Only second to
Napa Valley, California.
So the tourism that
we get is incredible,
but we're still trying to
promote our wines worldwide,
and to make a real
name for ourselves.
So I thought it'd be really fun
to try some wines together.
- [Gary] Thrilled to do it.
- And I imagine you still
drink wine from time to time.
- [Gary] Once in a blue moon.
- Okay.
- [Gary] Cool.
- So we have a few wines here,
from Pillitteri
Winery, of course,
my family business.
And we're going to
also do some sparkling wine
from Jackson-Triggs.
Now I wanted to just jump
right into a big, juicy red.
For our winery, we're very proud
of every wine that we make.
But when we're
tasting wine together today,
what I really wanna do is just,
see if you can notice some
difference in characteristics,
and if you can really pick out,
maybe what grape
this is for example.
What a fun game.
I get to play guess which
grape this is with GaryVee.
(audience laughter)
- Alright, let's see.
- Single varietal.
- Okay. So on the sniffy
sniff, as I used to call it,
there's a little
hint of blackberry.
There's a little charcoal
kind of actual aspect to it.
I'm getting a little
vegetal on the nose,
so let's give it a whirl.
It's pretty good.
- [Richard] Thank you.
(audience laughter)
- I was pumped.
I was like, I'm gonna
destroy his wine in his face.
(audience laughter)
But it's pretty good.
Very clean.
Nice tannins.
You know, really sweet tannins,
which I'm sure makes.
How many people drink wine?
Great, so.
The one big
thing with red wines,
the reason it takes
people time to get used to it,
is that bitter
taste on the back end,
the skins from the
grape, the tannins.
This has like
Cabernet Franc characteristics.
- It's 100% Cabernet Franc.
(audience applause and cheers)
- Guys, long before I was
cool in the business world,
I was cool in the wine world.
I've got other talents.
Nice, yeah, it feels like
a really strong cab franc.
So I love Loire Valley reds,
which are cabernet franc based.
They're more
vegetal than this is,
this is a little more fruit.
But the reason I was able to
kind of distinct the varietal,
was because the
California cabernet franc craze,
has more sunshine to it.
I was a little confused because
the weather patterns here,
so it just speaks to
the quality of the grapes,
which I think is
a great indication
of what you guys are doing.
- Yeah thank you.
So cabernet franc, for those
of you guys who didn't know,
is actually one of the most
widely planted
grapes here in Ontario,
because it ripens so well.
It ripens at about, end
of October, mid October.
And for us this
is a 2012 reserve.
We do 24 months in
French oak barrels,
and it's our premium red wine
that we've been
showcasing all around the world.
So obviously when
I'm going, you know,
China, Japan, Germany,
we export a third of
our products overseas,
which is pretty amazing.
35 different countries in total.
Cabernet Franc has
always been our number one red,
so I'm glad you picked it out,
and you really enjoyed it.
In terms of the
next wine we have,
this is a sparkling wine
from Jackson-Triggs.
- While you open that
let me just say one thing
while we're wine nerding it out.
Here is the.
I was starting to
pen the book in my head,
which is how I do it.
I was gonna come
out with the wine diet,
which was gonna talk about how
I basically watched
anybody who came from being
somewhat into wine
and interested in wine,
to really getting
to a place where they
loved it and
enjoyed it quite a bit.
And the whole
concept was predicated on.
The fact of
the matter is, again,
how many people here drink
wine multiple times a week,
raise your hands,
just to get a sense.
Here's the thing--
Buncha alcoholics around here.
(audience laughter)
The big thing
that happens in wine
is people find a wine they
like, either a brand or a type,
and they drink it for
the rest of their lives.
They drink,
whether it's Cabernet Franc
or whether it's Jackson-Triggs
or whether it's Chardonnay,
they just drink it forever.
And so the wine diet
was gonna be forcing people
to drink 365 different
types of wine in one year.
If you're genuinely
getting into wine
or wanna get more
into it, the number one way
to really become someone
who can really appreciate it
is to force yourself to try
different wines
from different regions.
So Cabernet
Sauvignon from California
is gonna act differently
than one from Australia,
and then trying grape
varietals like Petit Verdot
or Chenin Blanc or
a Malbec from Cahors
is gonna be
different than Argentina.
If you really wanna get there,
that's the way to do it.
- [Robert] Alight.
- Cool.
- [Robert] So sparkling wine is
what we're gonna jump to next,
and everyone
loves sparkling wine.
It's one of those easy wines
I find a lot of
people can get into.
- Who here doesn't
like sparkling wine
or champagne, raise your hands.
- Oh, that's a few.
- Not everybody
likes sparkling wine.
- That's okay, I didn't
make this one,
so that's okay, yeah (laughs).
- Good news, way more people
had no idea who the hell I was.
(audience laughter)
It's a pretty good too.
- Yeah, so--
- So I remember
seven, ten years ago,
I was really passionate
about Canadian wines,
Okanagan, here, to really
get them more into the U.S.
A lot wasn't coming in
and Jackson-Triggs really
caught my attention
12, 13 years ago,
producing really
high quality wines.
It's good to see
they're continuing that process.
Yeah, they've been a real
flagship winery in the region.
There's a few of us
that have been around
for that 20-plus years,
and it's nice because
we all carry that weight
together and Jackson-Triggs
being one of those big boys,
they produce a very consistent,
very well-rounded wine every
time, and you can just see
the bubble jumping
through this glass.
I know I'm talking
about all these wines,
we're drinking 'em now,
but we are gonna have 'em
for tasting outside with lunch.
- Oh, really?
- Yeah.
- Hey!
(audience applause)
- And as we move
forward, the very last wine
we're gonna pour,
coming from a family business
at Pillitteri, my
grandmother and grandfather,
they're at the winery every day.
You talk about your
experience growing up
and in terms of
the wine industry,
it really is that
story and that connection
that people have that
makes them remember things.
And the neat part
about coming to our winery
is that my grandmother
is the number one salesman
for this ice wine right here.
- That's awesome.
- So 74 years old,
in there every day,
and she just loves explaining
to people about this ice wine
they've never heard of before,
because we get visitors
that come to Niagara Falls
showing up from
all over the world,
and they are told
that you're gonna taste
the world's rarest wine.
And I know a lot
of people that say,
oh, this is special,
this is unique.
Ice wine can only be made in
a very special small climate,
which we have here in Niagara.
And ice wine is just
magically swirled in a glass.
If there's any
aromas jumpin' out...
- I'm about to tell a story
I haven't told in a long time.
When I was
single in New York City,
ice wine was a very big
part of my dating strategy.
(audience laughter)
'Cause it's so
delicious, you can drink
that whole little
bottle in you know...
(audience laughter)
Who likes sugar,
raise your hands.
This stuff is so good.
- Yeah.
- And when you compare
it to the great Sauternes
of the world that
tend to be four to 50 times
more expensive, for
98% of the drinking public,
they're not gonna taste
the nuanced differences that
separate it, and that speaks
to the quality of these wines.
And what's really
crazy about these wines,
a lot of youngsters,
here's what I would say.
The thing I find most
fascinating about these
ice wines is they will age
literally for 30, 40, 60 years.
And they're
priced in a way that,
so a lot of my friends
who are now 40 years old
are super-thankful for me
because I pushed 'em on,
including yours, ice wine,
which now they have,
they bought when they were 25.
They're 15 years old, they're
really interesting wines.
They're gonna last longer,
and I told 'em to buy a case
and pour it at
their daughter's wedding
or their kid's wedding,
so I always think...
Back to living
your life, the moments,
me in the arcade,
John, that stuff,
to me, that's what I loved
about wine, which is
it's really cool, and there's
a lot of youngsters in here
that you can go and buy six
bottles or something like this,
put it away somewhere
that it can store,
and really open it
40 or 50 years later
and be like, that GaryVee guy
who's like the
number one human on earth,
he was the one who
told me to buy this.
But it will last forever.
- Yeah.
And it's really fun.
The Niagara wine industry
has so many different wines,
so many different styles,
whether it's Baco Noir
or Cabernet Franc or ice
wine, but there's no question,
ice wine's what's kinda built
up our whole industry here.
When people think of Canada,
the first thing that pops
into their head is ice wine.
And we're very lucky.
Like I said, we ship this
to 35 different countries.
It's crazy, if you see it
around the world sometimes.
Catches you off guard
if you're on vacation,
or you go to Las Vegas,
and obviously things
are more expensive
in Las Vegas,
but you see the bottle,
which is $50, $60 here--
- Las Vegas is another
good place to bring ice wine.
- Yeah.
(audience laughter)
- Thank you.
- It's more expensive right--
- Congratulations.
- Thanks so much for everything.
- Yeah, thank you for
letting me taste this.
- It's just fun
to taste some wines.
- Ton.
- Glad you've heard of
Niagara and Pillitteri.
- Oh, of course.
Know it super well.
Thank you.
- Cheers.
(audience applause)
- Richard Slingerland,
Pillitteri Estates.
Thank you so much.
We have one more guest up here
to see you for a quick sec
first before I do that I have
a bit of housekeeping here,
just one quick thing.
There is a red Ford F-150
it's license plate
is AK48326.
- This is not real.
- No, it's real.
It's parked illegally and
it's going to be towed but
I think that this
happened an hour a go so,
(audience laughter)
you might be running
after your car so once again,
Ford F-150 AK48326.
- This is the best
conference I've ever been to.
- Can you imagine?
(audience applause)
Okay my next order of business,
if people could please
take out their bingo cards,
I'm totally kidding.
(audience laughter)
No, I was just joking.
Alright, I want to bring another
guest out he's got a gift
for you he was a running back
for 10 years with the
Edmonton Eskimos--
- Amazing.
- of the Canadian
Football League.
Five time Gray Cup Champion.
- Wow.
- He's also of course because
of those accolades a member
of the Canadian
Football Hall of Fame.
He's the athletic director
right now at Brock University.
(audience cheers)
There he goes, coach.
He was with his daughter
Kristen on amazing race and his
son Jesse Lumsden after a
successful yet short career in
the CFL is now
representing Canada 2018
for his second Olympic game.
This is NeIl Lumsden.
(audience applause and cheers)
- Is this on,
can everyone hear me?
Just so security knows,
that's my truck,
don't touch my truck,
whoever it is.
- How are you?
- Great to meet you.
- Such a pleasure.
- A great day, it's my pleasure.
- Jesus, some
serious guns under here.
(audience laughter)
- Yeah well curls get girls.
Listen, I was asked to and
clearly it doesn't work for
those that are paying attention.
I'm today's bag man
but more importantly,
thank you for a lot of things
you talked about and a lot
of things you said they
resonated not only with me but
with everyone else.
It also reminds me
how lucky I've been,
and it all resonated but one
of the things that really
resonated when you
talked about a firefighter
and firefighters
and that attitude.
I've had the good fortune
from university to whatever
time it is right now to be
around people that
always ran in,
didn't run out.
And that's one of the reasons
I think I've had a lot of
fun in life so
thanks for reminding me.
But more importantly
on a football front,--
- Yes.
- the Super Bowl is over,--
- Yes, thank God.
(audience laughter)
- But our national championship,
the Grey Cup Game, was played
in November and I was
involved in a few of them,
all successful I'm pleased
to say and as you probably
know for national championships
they make so many
footballs that are
branded for the Grey Cup.
- Yes.
- So I thought it's
appropriate that given you're a
football fan that we would
get you one of the few branded
balls from this year's Grey Cup
signed by our commissioner,
and I threw my
signature on there as well.
- I appreciate it.
(audience laughter and applause)
- And Pedro if you come
up and do a couple of flips,
you don't get one either.
Not impressive enough, buddy,
not impressive enough.
- He was ready though.
I like that speed, Pedro.
- But you're right
it's not good enough.
- Well, thank you.
- So on behalf of myself,
Brock University, athletes,
thank you.
- That's a real honor,
thank you very much.
- My pleasure.
- Thank you.
(audience applause)
- [Man] That's awesome.
- Thanks a lot.
- [Man] Thanks a
lot Neil, fantastic.
Gary, thank you
very much for your time.
- Thank you do I have to go?
- You are ready
to go if you need to.
- But I'll take
three selfies, let's go.
(upbeat music)